I'm Alan rap with wire design at the
24th international contemporary
furniture fair in New York this here
more than 500 exhibitors from global
manufacturers to small studios making
their debut are converging present their
visions for contemporary design we're in
the booth of virginia tech school of
architecture and design who are
developing a house of the future
prototype with interior modular wall
systems in a variety of projects that
are representing new kinds of dynamic
skins and building facades the panels
back here are from a previous Solar
Decathlon winning project and these are
all angled so that depending on whether
you're in winter or summer months you've
got more light coming in or less an
on-site weather station is going to send
data to these control systems and that's
what's going to make for real
optimization cross ventilation privacy
control insulation and heat retention
are all combined with this data system
so the house of the future actually is
going to have robots but they're not
going to be like servants they're going
to be more integrated into the
structures and the skin of the building
itself
the forms and the projects in Europe
really caught my eye what are we looking
at here so what you're looking at is our
lighting collection which is all one of
a kind generative 3d printed lamps so
what our company nervous system does is
we really write software that's based on
scientific research of how different
types of patterns form in nature and
then we use that to create one-of-a-kind
designs so you're 3d printing lets us
make every piece unique since it's not
molded we can take advantage of the
generative techniques and programming to
create complex geometry that you can
make otherwise in the future we're going
to see a lot more of these intersections
between engineering computing rapid
prototyping and design
Universal kinetic ink has developed this
modular system which at first glance
looks like a mechanical futon but it's
really a lot more sophisticated than
that their research is looking into the
way that our demographic is going to be
aging and want to be aging more on site
at home so this is a system which can
have you up right also extend as a bed
but some of the more sophisticated
notions are here in the control systems
this haptic system this grip the smart
grip it responds to the force of your
squeeze this grip system is going to be
able to control the atmospherics as well
as the television itself eventually the
whole mechanics of the bed
so this environment is pavilion made
entirely out of paper a 12-foot high
pavilion made of paper fans by Mulder's
ines good for exhibition halls but also
interior systems partitions this tables
the stools that I'm sitting on are good
for up to 60 pounds per 12 linear inches
so as we're looking for more sanctuaries
in the urban environment we have this
material that gets off this very calming
effect and you can create an entirely
soothing experience from
these were a few glimpses from the 2012
icff this just might be what the house
of the future looks like
you